[Music]
[Applause]
he's Josh dumel the actor former
quarterback at Minot State University
Die Hard Vikings fan and he's got a new
movie shotgun wedding Josh and Jennifer
Lopez that's available uh coming up on
Prime video on January 27th all right
you get to pick
we started out with the Vikings or you
want to talk about making out with JLo
I want to talk about fritzy's let's get
quizzical
oh no I wanna get quizzical that was
Precious Precious stuff Precious
Precious here it is
good sports radio conversation you gotta
answer it just right you know what I
mean don't Google it just try to think
it out challenge yourself mentally make
sure you know what you're talking about
or get embarrassed on radio and TV let's
get quick okay
Olivia Newton-John had died two days
earlier Josh
yeah that was a serious tribute my
fritzy to Olivia Newton-John God rest
yourself we all mourn in different ways
[Laughter]
oh
good to see you good to see you
um I've been I've been hounding you yes
yes I can talk whatever you'd like I
mean we could talk football first if
you'd like well what should we talk
about what I've been texting you about
first sure
this is just about every weekend I hear
from Josh and you'd think newly married
he's got a movie I'm like he's got other
things to worry about but nope this is
first and foremost on his mind go ahead
foreign
I don't know why anybody's not talking
about why Cooper Rush is not playing
quarterback instead of deck Prescott
Cooper Rush played way better than Dax
play since he's been back
and nobody wants to talk about it they
talk about Dak as if he's I don't know
Patrick Mahomes or something like that
job is secured like like it's in Fort
Knox and nobody's going to take it from
him well it better be secure they're
paying him a whole lot of money that is
that the reason why they keep them in
there because they're not going to win
this weekend I don't think the way he's
been playing you think Cooper Rush is
better than Dak Prescott I think he's
more of a he he have less chance to make
mistakes he doesn't make as many
mistakes and he's as good of a passer he
gets the ball to The Playmakers and they
score points and they win football yeah
Paulie do that Cooper Rush's stance yeah
Cooper Rush this year four and one is a
starter five touchdowns three picks his
quarterback rating was 84. okay
I don't know if those are I mean is that
enough of a sample size for you to go
I'm going to turn the keys over to
Cooper rush I'm just saying when it
comes down to this time of the year you
net you have to win who do you feel more
comfortable with I don't know man
I'm going Cooper if you I think that I
think it's going to be a short Leash too
if he doesn't come out and play well
they might go to him quick
wow
you you should be on first take or
Undisputed or whatever that show's
called am I that crazy
that's that's pretty controversial what
is it okay tell me what he's done that's
been that that you that you trust Jack
Prescott right now more than Cooper Rush
um I do think Cooper Rush knows what he
can and can't do
more so than Dak does and Dak did lead
the league in interceptions and missed
like five games uh and still led the
league in interceptions you know this is
where you find out how good your
quarterbacks are regular season doesn't
mean anything these are the games
you know this is why you have Tom Brady
not during the regular season postseason
this this is why certain quarterbacks
you feel more confident with Patrick
Mahomes or Joe burrow now
then you know you would with these other
quarterbacks that they're facing there's
a reason for that but what about Kirk
Cousins you think he's got what it takes
this year
okay what are your expectations if it's
a day game then I like Kirk Cousins it's
when the Sun goes down so does he and
the lights get bright yes that's what
worries me about him too but I feel like
he is okay this is my honest take on it
I think that they've had so many games
this year that have been so tight and
they've been able to win those games and
in the past they lose those games they
find a way to lose and this this year
they found ways to win
um when they get beat they get their
asses kicked
I mean you look at that Eagles game you
look at the Cowboys game you look at the
Packers game
and I think the the lions with the
fourth loss not as much of a butt
kicking but yeah they just seem to win
barely or they get I think they got
outscored in overall points yeah
throughout the season yeah but here
here's here's my points I think that
because they have that they do have a
lot of talent even defensively they have
the talent
if they can gel and and one of these
teams is going to catch fire at this
time of year and they're going to make a
big run and I don't see why the Vikings
can't be that team they've got the
players they've got the coach
and I'm just hoping for that and I'm
hoping that Kirk is able to get over
that that hump that he seems to be how
many years have I spoken to you
after a Vikings playoff loss
many yeah yeah they find a new way to
break my heart again they do we're
talking to Josh dumel
um the Die Hard Vikings fan in the new
movie on Prime video January 27th with
Jennifer Lopez it's called shotgun
wedding
how well did you know JLo before you did
the movie
I knew her fairly well I met her years
ago
at like a New Year's
party in Miami and we hung out a bit we
she was with I think she's Marc Anthony
at the time
um and we went on this big boat and we
just sort of that was the first time I'd
met her and she was super cool so I knew
that I knew that she wasn't like some
you know girl that you can't really get
to
uh uh and so I so when we had this we
had a zoom call
uh when that one that when they wanted
me to do the part just to sort of talk
to her again and talk to the director
and right off the bat we you know we we
got along great and she's just an
awesome girl I don't know she's she is
JLo but she's also still Jenny From the
Block a little bit okay now explain the
kissing scenes
walk us through the preparation of
making out with Jayla
I'm not gonna lie there was a little bit
of nervousness going into that it was
like you know you step outside yourself
I'm about to kiss JLo
do you rehearse actually make sure my
breath is good I actually put some gum
in and tried to hide it uh and like
halfway through the seat she's like are
you chewing gum yeah
yeah they made me spit at us so if you
watch the movie you'll see there's a
couple spots where I'm actually chewing
gum in that scene
what's rehearsal like
um
surprisingly normal I mean again we got
along I wasn't if I didn't know her
before it'd be hard to get over the
whole
you know Superstar aspect of who she is
but she's just a normal chick and we had
a we had it was very easy it wasn't it
wasn't as nerve-wracking as as it might
seem but when you do rehearsal do you
kiss during rehearsal oh uh
I don't remember I think I think maybe
just maybe a little
not like the full-on yeah I mean you got
to be you got to be respectful I mean I
don't want Ben Affleck showing up at my
front door but was she was not dating
Ben at the time I don't want I don't
want I don't want uh that was a rod no
showing up at my house with a shotgun
you could take out rod you think so yeah
probably in a fight I don't know man
it's pretty big did he show up on set
when you were with his then girlfriend
he did he did
and they were going through it at the
time so it was it was a bit of yeah so
she was on the rebound and you were
there for her oh God here we go
[Laughter]
you think that's why he showed up he
made maybe he was a little worried I
would remember I was a happily uh
engaged no I wasn't engaged
they could have got steamy
that could have been a good opportunity
you could have been the you know come
over you know let's talk okay how can I
help you how can I help I'll be that guy
yeah
come here yeah
I'm a good listener
[Laughter]
the movie is shotgun wedding I was
surprised
at the the gore in here the violence in
here
have you seen the movie I have seen
clips of the movie okay but like I
thought it would be a rom-com
and it and it changed yeah quick you
know what's great about it is Jay Moore
Jason Moore who's the director who
directed Pitch Perfect and
I don't know if you've ever seen Avenue
Q in New York but he would he's a really
he's got a very specific sort of
sensibility about his his comedy and he
was he really kind of went it's a it's a
it's a heightened sort of almost Broad
in its comedy in some ways they it's
it's really uh it was fun to play
because he just absolutely went for it
there's one scene where
where she's got this she steals this
grenade from one of these Pirates who
are trying to overtake the resort and
I'm a former baseball player I grabbed
this this piece of art that looks like a
bat and she tosses it to me and I hit it
and I hit it to the blow up and and
literally I blow up one of these guys to
pieces and there's a few moments like
Lenny Kravitz for example at the end of
the movie I'm not gonna give too much of
it away but dyes in a very graphic way
like they didn't pull any punches on
that I was like wow I just saw Lenny
Kravitz
disintegrate
well doesn't JLo use the wedding knife
to decapitate somebody
well she uses it to well she uses it to
to cut apart a a the Rope that's
connecting him from the boat to this
parachute that he's hanging on and then
that happens
it's not a wrong it's I'm you know I
want people to know that it's not a
rom-com yeah but it it it's it I mean it
is romantic and it is comedic but it's
also a lot of action and it is pretty
graphic which I loved I thought it was
but in a funny way of course like it's
not gonna you're not gonna have to turn
your head it's funny Gore uh it's funny
Jennifer Coolidge who has had this
revitalization Stifler's mom is uh in
there she's uh White Lotus uh Lenny
Kravitz is also in there uh Cheech of
Cheech and Chong in there as well yeah
he plays he plays her mom her dad yeah
Jennifer Coolidge plays my mother which
is weird because she's like
nine years older than me if that no so
she's very promiscuous at a very young
age okay all right
um well congrats on uh getting married
thank you Dan and I know that you uh
thank you for the lovely gift by the way
you invited me uh and from what I hear I
probably could have helped you you know
not injure yourself
on your was that the night before
that you got hurt yeah it was that was
pretty nuts when I when I really looked
back at it uh it was it was uh we had we
had this band uh that we had play at the
rehearsal dinner and it was like this
little party before the party and I had
a couple and decided to go into the
party bus after we're driving back to
the hotel
and I tried one of these I was dancing I
tried one of those gymnastics moves
where you know the they're oh they were
on the Rings and they're able to pull
themselves up and like make their legs
go straight out well I tried doing that
and my back went
and I knew it right there I was like oh
that's not going to be good in the
morning sure enough I wake up and I
can't get out of bed
like two hours before I'm supposed to be
walking down the aisle I can't stand up
and I'm and I'm already I'm already a
little bit insecure about how much older
I am I'm I'm quite a bit older than her
so I was like oh my God I'm gonna have
to walk down the aisle on a walk
[Music]
did you complete the process though like
I did so I went to the hospital I got
shot up with some Toradol made it
through the day without any pain dance
did the whole thing and then woke up the
next morning after the wedding and
couldn't get out of bed again
had to go back to the hospital
yeah and it took a couple months for it
to recover it was a pretty pretty I
don't know what I did but it wasn't good
soft
what you're right yeah what happened to
you no it's soft shotgun wedding with
JLo watch uh Josh make out with JLo do
you think Ben Affleck will watch this
movie
um yeah I hope he does I think he's
going to be at the premiere on on
Wednesday I think I think he's going to
watch it
I think he could take Ben Affleck in
what a fight yeah or one-on-one
well I would take you one-on-one but a
fight
uh
fight with Ben Affleck that'd be pretty
good we're both about the same size
um
yeah yeah I think it'd be a good match
actually yeah does he wrestle because
I'm I'm a college wrestler I don't know
if you knew that no I did not know that
what Paulie we were thinking like the
town Ben Affleck he was pretty jacked
you don't want to mess with that that
Ben Affleck in the movie The Town yeah
he was jacked yeah yeah he was he's he
and he was jacked when he was Batman so
and I am not jacked right now I'm
actually on I was I spent two weeks out
at the cabin
our three weeks out of the cabin in
Minnesota and and my my diet was Busch
Light
cookies and frozen pizza so I'm on a
cleanse right now you ever done a
cleanse no
oh dude I'm on a cleanse right now I've
never done it either it's hard yeah I'm
Dr I'm literally drinking liquids for
four days straight well you don't want
to look too old because your wife is so
young I'm trying to stay young I'm
trying to keep this body
Ship Shape you know what I mean yeah he
expects that of me yeah yes yeah
um well good luck with the movie no more
importantly good luck with the Vikings
against the Giants hey thank you and
also thank you guys for the uh you
you're gonna you're gonna love the
little bit you did for buddy games too
it looks fantastic so when do but when's
that movie come out buddy games two well
we just literally turned it in to
Paramount like two days ago so whatever
they decide to let it
if you didn't see buddy games one
is that going to make it tougher to
watch buddy games too
you should see the first one but they're
not they're not necessarily okay I'm
connected but one of the characters uh
uh in as you know one of the characters
passes at the opening of this one and
you guys were helpful in in sort of
setting that whole thing up yeah
well uh good luck with your uh your
Vikings this weekend and thank you thank
you
come on Kirk Cousins
here we go that's uh that's Josh dumel
Vikings apologist